hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
meine super leckere mond orte die habe
ich noch getoppt mit sahne und schmand
und für die deko noch ein paar pistazien
darüber gegeben
der kuchen passt in jede jahreszeit
wunderbar hinein gerade jetzt im winter
bereitet den aber am liebsten zu und
jetzt zeige ich euch zuallererst die
zutaten wir benötigen blauen zucker und
ich habe hier noch etwas vanille zucker
mit dazu genommen
außerdem weichweizen gries neutrales öl
ich hab sonnenblumenöl verwendet und den
abrieb einer bio orange oder ihr nehmt
es einfach fertig aus dem back regal
zuallererst werden die eier zusammen mit
dem zucker und dem vanillezucker in der
küchenmaschine richtig schön cremig
geschlagen
nach ca 5 minuten erhaltet ihr eine
richtig schöne helle cremige masse und
dann geht es auch schon weiter um
vergeben die restlichen zutaten mit dazu
wir geben also das öl hin zu den
weichweizen gries den glauben und zu
guter letzt unsere ab geriebene
orangenschale und die sorgt meiner
meinung nach wirklich für einen
erheblichen unterschied im geschmack
jetzt wird alles nur noch ganz kurz
miteinander verrührt und zwar so lange
bis sich die zutaten miteinander
verbunden haben
und so sieht die fertige monastir jetzt
aus ich gehe mit dem teich aber immer
noch gern ein bisschen nach damit sich
auch wirklich alles miteinander
verbindet und dann gebe ich das denn
meine vorbereitete springform die hat
bei mir eine größe von 26 cm und gibt
sie in den backofen
im vorgeheizten backofen wird der
mondkuchen jetzt bei 170 grad für ca 30
bis 35 minuten gebacken für unseren
zuckersirup benötigen wir wasser zucker
und ein wenig zitronensaft
auf dem herd geht's jetzt weiter und
hier gebe ich ihnen mein kochtopf das
wasser und den zucker und lasse das
aufkochen
der zucker sirup durfte bei mir zwei
minuten köcheln dann gehen wir noch den
zitronensaft mit dazu und lassen das
ganze auskühlen
mein kuchen kommt gerade ganz frisch und
heiß aus dem backofen und hier steche
ich mit meinem thermostat ein paar
löcher 1
das ist zugegebenermaßen aus der not
heraus entstanden ihr können natürlich
sehr gerne auch ein schaschlikspieß
benutzen und dann gebe ich den
abgekühlten zuckersirup auf den noch
heißen kuchen der zucker sirup darf auch
ruhig noch ganz leicht lauwarm sein
wärmer dann allerdings nicht sollte dann
schon etwas abgekühlt sein damit der
kuchen den sirup schön aufnehmen kann
und nicht matschig werte wir wollen ihn
einfach nur saftig haben und jetzt
bedecke ich den kuchen und lass ihn
vollständig auskühlen für das topping
benötigen wir ganz kalte schlagsahne
schmandt außerdem seiner tat und vanille
extrakt
die kalte schlagsahne wird zusammen mit
dem salat und dem vanille extrakt steif
geschlagen
anschließend wird der stand ganz kurz
mit eingerührt und dann ist unser
topping auch schon fertig
bevor ihr jetzt weitermacht ist es ganz
wichtig dass der mond kuchen mit dem
zucker sirup einmal komplett durchwühlt
bei mir war das hier zu vier stunden
lang im kühlschrank und jetzt gebe ich
dass seine schmandt topping darüber
für die deko gebe ich den kuchen auf
meine torten dreh platte und machen mit
hilfe einer gabel ein paar spiral muster
in die saane schmandt creme
abschließend wird der kuchen noch mit
gehackten pistazien dekoriert und dann
ist ja auch schon sofort sehr wir bereit
den mohnkuchen müsst ihr unbedingt mal
ausprobiert haben falls ihr mond fans
seid denn der schmeckt nicht nur total
saftig durch den zuckersirup hat auch
eine leichte fruchtige note das liegt an
den orangenschalen und vor allem durch
den grieß habt ihr eine richtig schöne
feine konsistenz
und wie ihr seht auch kinder leben den
mohnkuchen
die genauen mengenangaben stehen wie
immer unten in der infobox und falls ihr
jetzt noch lust habt auf einen leckeren
käse kuchen oder einen grandiosen apfel
schwand kuchen dann schaut mal hier habe
ich euch die zwei videos noch verlinkt
und ich freue mich wenn ihr auch beim
nächsten mal wieder dabei sein